so how did you get on uh Gotti's radar I
was doing my own thing and
um it's like a neighborhood hero that I
was looking up to in the streets right
and that was one of the guided people
that he raised so
um he put the book in murder and so but
he basically telling me like keep going
like they watching type [__] it's like
you're a big homie was somebody who was
type of Gotti yeah and that was kind of
how yeah yeah yeah he put the word in
and put the word in like they were they
were like look at they were like who hot
in the city and he brought my name up so
he was like hey bro they looking at you
they and they start looking at me but he
didn't tell me when they was coming he
was like they just looking at you man
like just keep going and he'll tell you
when they're coming what year did you
sign like how long would you sign 2018.
yeah so you were you were a part of the
uh July 26th the awesome press
conference the CMG press conference last
year when mozzie got announced uh-huh
yeah by the way yeah free Mozzy for sure
I just wrote him in jail yeah yeah yeah